New attacks on
the capital, Kyiv,
after weeks of relative calm.
Ukraine's armed forces say
Russia unleashed,
at least unleashed at least 12 drones,
but it says most were destroyed
and there were no casualties or damage.
This as Russian state
media says,
a large blast
in the Russian city of Belgorod
close to the Ukrainian border was caused
by an emergency
release of an air ordnance
from a Russian warplane.
There was significant damage.
At least one analyst
described the scenario as odd.
Let's bring in Ben Wedeman.
He joins me from Kiev.
It does sound rather odd
right?
Odd indeed.
This happened at about 10:15 o'clock
last night local time, wherein
some 35 twin engine fighter bomber
dropped a bomb.
I mean,
the use of this emergency
release of an airborne of an air
ordnance, they dropped a bomb
on a busy street
in the middle of this city of 400,000
people.
Now we saw on CCTV that
the hit sort of on a sidewalk
by the side of this busy
road causing one car to fly up
into the air.
Now according to the mayor of Belgorod,
two people were injured in this incident.
Now it is odd
that this would happen
in the middle of the town.
Normally if
a pilot is experiencing problems,
if he has to drop his bomb by mistake,
but because of technical difficulties,
he would do it in
an unpopular shaded area,
not in the middle of a city.
No.
Belgorod is only 40 kilometers
from the border with Ukraine
and on more than one occasion,
the Ukrainians have fired back
in the direction of that city,
I think
in the early months,
weeks of the war, actually.
A Ukrainian helicopter
conducted a strike on the city.
I think sometimes it's hit by Ukrainian
drones as well.
But this incident certainly will jog
it will be jarring
to many of the residents
of that city Max.
Okay, Ben, thank you.
The U.S.
says Western
allies have now provided $55 billion
in security assistance to Ukraine
and are promising
to build on their progress.
The US defense
secretary spoke at the Ukraine Defense
Contact Group
meeting in Ramstein, Germany,
where he had
where he said America rejects
Vladimir Putin's view of the world.
All of
us have come together
to stand up for Ukraine
and for a world
based on rules and rights.
We reject Putin's grim vision of a world
where tyrants get to assault
their peaceful neighbors
and try to impose self self-declare
spheres of influence at gunpoint.
Also speaking from Rammstein,
the head of NATO's,
who said the alliance remains committed
to Ukraine's eventual membership.
All Needle allies have agreed
that Ukraine will become a NATO member,
but the main focus now is, of course, on
on how to ensure that Ukraine prevails.
Sebastian here with more.
And Ukraine always wants more than
what is being promised.
Would you expect
they're going to get today?
Well, so we know so far
that Alexi Reznik
of who is the defense
minister, has had a bilateral meeting
with the U.S.
defense secretary,
Lloyd Austin, who you just saw there.
He said it was fruitful.
We don't know exactly
what kind of promises were made.
The US went into this meeting
saying there were three key issues
air defense, ammunition
and what they call enablers,
which are things that sort of help
the overall mission,
things like heavy duty
trucks and stuff to transport equipment.
The Ukrainian side went into it
specifically asking for NATO's
standard fighter jet.
So it would seem that
there is some daylight.
But of course, they are
very clear
rhetorically exactly
that the NATO's side
that they are in this
for the long haul,
that they stand with Ukraine
are going to continue
to tailor their response
to the situation on the battlefield.
I think the other elephant in the room,
clearly at this
meeting is the issue of those Pentagon
leaks, how that happened.
The U.S.
trying to smooth things
over a little bit with its allies.
Take a listen
to what Lloyd Austin had to say
about that.
As I've
discussed this
issue with our allies and partners,
I've been struck by your solidarity
and your commitment
to reject efforts to divide us.
And we will not let anything
fracture our unity
So it would seem
that's not just a message to
his allies in the room,
but also to Moscow
that NATO is standing firm
in its support for Ukraine.
We did get come in in response
not to that,
but to the comments
from the NATO's secretary general
saying that the alliance
is essentially united on the view
that Ukraine
should join the Kremlin, saying
that Neato continues
to show its aggressive nature.
They said
we're dealing with a dangerous bloc
that counts our country as an enemy.
Okay, Clare, thank you.